And now I'd like to present our speaker
today, Professor Julia Novy-Hildesley.
Julia Novy-Hildesley is
Professor of the Practice and
Executive Director of Stanford's Change
Leadership for Sustainability Program.
This includes the Leadership for
Sustainability Executive Education Program
as well as the Sustainability Science and
Practice Interdisciplinary Master's
degree.
With 20 years experience leading nonprofit
and philanthropic organizations, Julia's
research and teaching focuses on business
strategies, leadership approaches and
cross-sector partnerships that
spur global development and
align systems with the goal of
intergenerational well-being.
The Change Leadership Program explores
the mindsets, knowledge and tools leaders
needs to accelerate the transition to
a more sustainable and resilient society.
These include understanding
complex systems,
leading organizational change, and
innovating in complex systems at scale in
order to shift suboptimal status quo
orientations toward sustainability.
And Julia will be talking about some of
these themes today throughout the webinar.
So with that I'd like to
turn it over to Julia.
>> Hello there and welcome to webinar.
Glad to have you joining us.
Today, I'm going to cover three
core questions and themes.
First, why build
a sustainable organization?
Second, what orientations are required to
thrive in today's operating environment?
And, third, how to integrate
sustainability at the core and
throughout your organization.
So let's start first by talking
about sustainability and
what sustainability means.
Sustainability is really a term
that has often been associated
with green concepts, and
doing environmental good.
But, in fact, if you look at really
what sustainability means more broadly,
it's a very holistic, systemic
definition that's important to consider.
So, for example, economic,
social and environmental factors we
hear when business talks
about the triple bottom line.
The Brundtland Report is the first
report that really made an effort in
1987 to define what
sustainable development is.
And it looks at the interactions
between human beings and
their natural environment.
Basically saying that the environment
is the place where we live, and
development is what we do
within that environment.
And therefore sustainable development is
thinking about how we go about improving
our condition while maintaining the
quality of the environment where we live.
Another really important thing to remember
about sustainability, in addition to it
being a holistic term incorporating
social, economic and environmental values,
is that it is a long-term
view on development.
And it's a very integrated view.
So, for example, it is not just about some
folks doing well at the expense of others.
But it's really about a holistic
view of all people doing well.
And it's about doing well
over time across generations.
We often use the term intergenerational
well-being to describe what we mean
by sustainability.
So one can't really understand
sustainability without
thinking about systems.
Here in this diagram you see
the economy nested within society and
nested within the environment.
When you think about systems,
you think about complex nonlinear dynamic
interactions that occur between economy,
society and the environment.
Jane Jacobs, an urban philosopher, reminds
us that the economy is a wholly owned
subsidiary of the environment,
and not the other way around.
So with this in mind, we have to move
a little bit from maybe our more linear,
productive approaches
to problem solving and
thinking, and pick a more holistic,
systemic view.
This cartoon shows a group of
blind men with an elephant,
working to understand
what they're looking at.
And, of course, they're all looking
at different parts, separately, and
getting fragmented views of what's going.
It's like taking a systems perspective,
and exchanging information about different
parts of the system, so that they
can come to a full understanding.
Let's talk about how we hear in business
the global environment characterized.
VUCA World is a concept that was coined
by the US Army War College to describe
a multilateral world after the Cold War,
where things were much more in flux.
And it has been used now since
the late 1990s in business to describe
the volatility,
uncertainty, complexity and
ambiguity of the business
operating environment.
And, really, if you look at some of
the root causes of VUCA World, you see
that underlying these systems are the
dynamic interactions between social and
environment systems, and the increasing
stress we see that within those systems.
Whether from population growth,
or technology change,
or climate issues and resource scarcity,
civic strife, or political unrest.
These dynamics of the social
environmental systems are giving
rise to the context we call VUCA.
So given VUCA is characterized by
complexity, let's look a little bit more
closely at what differentiates
complicated from complex environments, or
complicated challenges
from complex challenges.
Complicated challenges are ones where
the problem is easily definable,
where existing know-how is adequate.
You can solve the challenge
with an existing blueprint or
algorithm or procedure.
You're in a fairly stable context
where outcome is fairly predictable.
You can plan for change.
And success depends on the blueprint that
directs both the development of separate
parts, and specifies the exact
relationship in which to assemble them.
So you can think of a Ferrari
as a complicated system.
You can take it all apart.
And then while it's very, very complex,
we can put it back together.
And the sum is simply equal to the parts.
In a complex environment or challenge
only parts of the problem are definable.
Expertise helps in the same way it
helps in a complicated challenge.
But it has to be balanced with
responsiveness because the environment is
changing.
The context is unstable,
the outcome is unpredictable.
And this, of course, means that
it requires constant adaptation,
improvisation and experimentation.
And in this case, you can't really
separate the parts from the whole.
The essence actually exists in
the relationship between the parts.
So you could think about a tropical
rainforest, for example, where you have
all the different species together in
dynamic interaction with one another.
And if you take it all apart, you will see
that actually the sum is much greater than
the individual parts
because of the interaction.
So the rainforest, for example,
produces rain on its own.
It recycles nutrients.
All of these functions happen
because of the interaction between
the different parts.
So here's a little cartoon that maybe
expresses our temptation to sometimes
look for the simple answers when we
are overwhelmed in a VUCA context.
That we are grappling with how
best to deal with complexity, and
to find the patterns and
navigation that will help us find our way
through complexity to
the visions we hope to achieve.
David Snowden in the late 1990s worked
to try and help us in this regard.
He developed the Cynefin framework.
Cynefin is a word that
means habitat in Welsh.
And you can see at the top left we have
environment characterized by complexity.
So what this commitment framework does
is it characterizes different habitats
of context.
And the aim is to help
the policy makers and
managers understand the different
context they might be in.
And then apply the right
problem solving approaches or
strategies based on that context.
So if you look at the complex content
in the upper left quadrant, what you
can see is that we need to apply intuitive
navigation from changing patterns.
So we need to look at pattern management
as a dominant strategy when dealing with
complexity.
And that by definition means a really
strong capacity to sense the environments
for perceived patterns.
And then to respond and
experiment accordingly based on
that strong sense in capacity.
If we look at natural ecological systems,
these systems like
the tropical rain forest have
millions of year of experience
in navigating changing
patterns in the context of complexity and
change.
And an interesting question to consider
whether or not understanding a bit
how the organisms wiithin the complex
open natural system like the rain forest.
And the system itself orient could
perhaps help business and organizations
think about how they might orient in
the context of change and complexity.
So let's look at some of the core
orientations of resilient,
open, natural systems.
First of all they are oriented to connect.
They have rich patterns of relationships
and very much of an interconnected,
interdependent communication
between the different elements.
They're also oriented to adapt, to
evolve and adapt to changing conditions.
To be in touch with a sensing capacity
to connect things with what's going on
in the environment.
And then to adapt accordingly
to explore new niches or
to evolve to suit a changing condition.
And then finally they're
orients to innovate,
to experiment and redesign,
to identify new ways of behaving and
designing oneself in the context
of a new environment.
So when you're thinking about building
a sustainable organization it's both
about placing sustainability
at the core with purpose.
But also applying the kinds
of orientation that really
enable an organization to thrive in
the context of complexity and change.
So you can see in this diagram the idea
that applying orientation of connect,
adapt and innovate.
Expands the capacity of the organization
because it has impact through its core
purpose.
So let's talk a little bit
about what these orientations
might look like in
the context of business.
So connect, for example would be about
broadening and deepening connections.
So broadening one's views,
seeing one's connection to the broader
context and operating environment.
And then, deepening the connection say,
for example through one's value chain.
You have more of a relationship focus
rather than a transaction focus to really
we understand the operations more deeply
and build the relationships accordingly.
It's about seeing the environment in
which you're operating from
a holistic perspective.
And that includes seeing all
the connections as well as seeing places
maybe where there are disconnections or
where the system is broken.
Adapt, is really about learning and
reorienting to be relevant,
being relevant to the changing context.
That means seeing the fuller
understanding of reality that you get
by greater connection.
And then expanding a notion of
responsibility because of that
understanding.
So that may mean moving from focus
on shareholders as the dominant and
only stakeholders to a much more broad and
inclusive view of stakeholders.
It may mean moving from the shorter term
focus on financial profitability to a more
inclusive longer term focus on social,
environmental and economic sustainability.
And then in terms of innovate it's
really about thinking creatively
about the opportunities presented
by the new context and designing.
And partnering for sustainability.
Taking some responsibility for
the ways in which the system
isn't working and jumping in and
redesigning systems.
So that they can work in this new context
and align with sustainability goals.
So in a moment we're going to talk
about a couple of organizations.
Look at two examples of organizations
that have put sustainability at the core.
And applied these orientations
to expand the impact and
profitability of their organization.
But first I'd like to do a quick poll and
check in with our group here about some of
the motivations that might
be behind your interest.
And your organization's interest
in engaging in sustainability.
So what I'd like to ask you or
what are the main driver for
integrating sustainability and into
the core purpose of your organization?
There's a set of options
there to choose from.
These are based on the report
the comprehensive report submitted
to the Harvard Business Reviews
on public last
that really looked at
the academic research.
And data that has been, for
the last couple of decades,
as to why companies are putting
sustainability at the core.
I'd be interested to hear what's
motivating your organization to do so
to the extent that it is.
So we'll pause for a moment.
Take some answers and then in a minute or
two be able to report back on the poll.
Okay, we'll close the poll.
It looks though fostering innovation
is one of the leading reasons.
And driving competitive advantage as well
as the tracking and engaging of employees,
that looks like that also
received quite a large number.
But all of the choices were selected.
Okay, great, thank you.
So let's look at a couple of case studies.
Unilever, a multinational consumer
goods company which reaches 2 billion
customers per day and
has over 170,000 employees.
And Sustainable Harvest, a specialty
coffee importer that imports about 20
million pounds of coffee per year.
And it's responsible for
about one-sixth of the fair trade
coffee sold in the United States.
So let's look at the orientation that
they're applying with sustainability
as their core purpose and
see what that actually means if
you translate that to business.
So first of all the connect orientation.
They are broadening their view,
looking at the broader context and
also deepening connections.
And they're doing this in three ways
that I'd like to discuss today.
One, their situating their organization
in the broader context, understanding
the role they play in that context and
how that context might affect them.
Second, they're building relationships
across their value chain and
third their connecting their core
purpose to the current reality.
So they're showing an alignment
between their core purpose and
the context they're operating in.
Second, the adapt orientation.
This is really about learning and
reorienting to be relevant.
So in the first place they're
reorienting goals and strategy to align
with the new sustainability orientation
and the contextual changes.
But they're also putting in place
metrics to measure progress.
Second they're aligning culture and
incentives.
The.
Phrase that culture often trumps
strategy is important here in this.
Without a culture that's
supportive of this realignment and
its learning, sustainability and
strategy will likely not be as effective.
And then finally, adopting a learning
orientation throughout the organization.
Third, innovating.
You all selected fostering innovation
as one of the core reasons for
putting sustainability at
the core of your organization.
This really is about designing and
partnering for sustainability.
First, through new products and
business models.
Second, by engaging broad
participation in problem solving.
So, harnessing a lot more resources
dedicated to that innovation.
And then finally, forging partnerships,
new kinds of partnerships.
Perhaps with unlikely bedfellows
to achieve scaled impact.
So, let's dig into Unilever a little bit.
As you probably know,
Unilever is an Anglo-Dutch
transnational consumer goods company.
It touches 2 billion customers per day.
And the CEO, Paul Polman, began his tenure
in 2009 and built on
the traditional values of Unilever,
but really began a very powerful and
focused emphasis on sustainability.
Focusing on growing and prospering
by tackling 21st century challenges.
Actually seeing as we pointed out in the
pool that by tackling these challenges for
innovation and therefore
productivity growth would increase.
So, one of the first things we talked
about was taking this systems approach.
He said business needs to take more of
a systems approach to their operations,
seeing companies as part of
an interconnected web that links multiple
players.
So, this is how he began his approach and
foray to thinking about operating
business services sustainability.
So, the first element of situating
in broader context aligned with
the connect orientation.
Unilever conducted a thorough
strategic review and
identified four megatrends
that affected its business.
The first has to do with shift in markets,
the world moving south and east,
in other words a strong
shift to emerging markets.
But then, recognizing that within these
markets, there was some fringe related
to income and resource scarcity that
would have impacts on the business.
Second, shift in lifestyles,
living differently.
A big move of globally from rural
to urban locations which then put
into question taxing already strained
infrastructure with this urban migration.
Also longer lives, people living longer.
All of these had implications for supply
chains and products and service designs.
Third, the environment under stress,
shift in the natural environment.
Recognizing water scarcity, climate
change, deforestation, poor sanitation
that the operating conditions for
business were increasingly under stress.
Which had big importation for
product development and manufacturing,
as well as pricing security issues.
And then finally, the digital revolution.
Looking at shift and
stakeholder empowerment through access to
information and
communication technologies.
In particular, recognizing that
citizens who were empowered to these
technologies required more transparency
and stakeholder engagement.
And that was required in order to
minimize the reputational risks and
the demands for
more stringent regulations.
The business might suffer if it didn't
effectively engaged the stakeholders So,
in addition to connecting with
the broader context, Unilever also has
placed a very strong emphasis on
connecting throughout the value chain.
So, not just the broader global
environment, but then really looking
across all of the value chains and
thinking about the relationship with
supplier and the impact of
the product within that value chain.
So, one step comment took early on was to
ask if managers to work across discipline,
to deepen relationship and
understanding across the value chain.
Working with producers and suppliers to
understand the environmental impact and
social impact of its product.
So, it conducted a life cycle analysis
of the company's top 13 brands.
And as you may know, a life cycle analysis
is technique that we used to thoroughly
assess the environmental impact associated
with all stages of a product's life.
From raw material extraction
through materials processing,
manufacture, distribution,
use, repair and maintenance.
So, through this connection
with the broader context,
connection with the value chain.
Unilever really is connected
with its core purpose and
built on founding values since the 1880s,
which were around responsible business.
Business developing products that
met the needs of the masses.
And we formulated that core purpose
to focus on what they thought was
to call the Unilever in the 21st century.
And that was to make
the sustainable living commonplace.
So, and it has adopted some of the,
One of the great system scientist
from the 20th century and
she talks about the tension of creating
what is in the staff to create a purpose.
In this case, making sustainable living,
common price, and
really understanding your current reality.
And the importance of really holding
both of those to create attention that
forces realignment and change and progress
hopefully towards achieving your purpose.
And this is where they adapt,
orientation comes in where businesses,
they need to think about,
how did they need to change and
reorient to achieve this core purpose
in the context of current reality?
Paul Polman came out and said,
we must develop a business model aimed at
contributing to society and the
environment instead of taking from them.
Somehow, you need to figure out what
the fitness model can look like and
we'll achieve that.
And so, they developed
a business model that situated
except around sustainable living.
Basically the idea was that profitable
volume growth would occur through
innovations that bring new sustainability
benefits to consumers and retailers.
That reducing waste and energy by
thinking about sustainability and
looking at looking at life
cycle analysis would save cost.
And that the risks to be managed in the
supply chain, which would secure long-term
sustainable sourcing of materials and
long-term viability of operations.
So, through this business plan,
it set out a vision and
a series of goals called
the sustainable living plan.
It was a vision to double the size
of their business while reducing its
environmental footprint and increasing the
positive social impact of the business.
This was set out in 2010 as
a ten-year vision for profitable and
sustainable growth.
Within that plan,
three concrete goals were identified.
It can help more than 1 billion people
to improve their health and well-being.
By 2020 to halve the environment
footprint of Unilever products.
And to source 100% of agricultural
raw materials sustainability and
enhance the livelihoods of millions
of people around the value chain.
Again, this is back to that expansion,
not just of connection but
a sense of responsibility
throughout the value chain.
Within the Sustainable Living Plan,
there are nine goals.
They center around three areas,
improving health and well-being,
reducing environmental impact and
enhancing livelihood.
Of course, goals need metrics to ensure
there's progress and Unilever brings
very strong on establishing over 50
targets associated with the goals and
then tracking progress and
reporting progress against their targets.
In this case, this is a 2014 Sustainable
Living Plan summary of progress and
one example, for example,
is the health and hygiene,
the goal was to help 1 billion
people improve hygiene habits.
By 2014, Unilever had reached 397
million people through sanitation,
safe drinking water, and
hand washing campaigns.
It has also have been reporting financial
and non-financial indicators next to
one another, to also cultivate that
awareness among all stakeholders,
the board all the way down to consumers,
that it is tracking both of these things.
Here you can see at the top, the more
traditional financial indicators and
below, non-financial indicators
around manufacturing.
For example,
looking at carbon generated and
water use for counter production,
waste and disposal and also,
issues around employee engagement and
diversity that are being tracked.
All this is happening in the context of
Unilever's share price doing quite well,
the two red lines there
on those two graphs,
compared to the S&P 500 on the left and
the FTSE 100 on the right.
Unilever continues to show
positive financial indicators and
in 2014, 50% of its growth came
from the Sustainable Living brand,
they grew at twice the rate
of the rest of the business.
In addition to aligning goals and
metrics with sustainability,
as we discussed earlier, aligning cultural
incentives is critical, so Unilever
has pursued a full integration of the
Sustainable Living Plan into its culture.
There are two board committees entirely
responsible for evaluating progress,
making recommendations, critiquing, issues
related to the Sustainable Living Plan.
Paul Polman early on decided
not to issue quarterly reports.
He wanted to underscore management
belief that investing in sustainability
takes time, and remuneration is tied
to achieving targets associated with
the Sustainable Living Plan.
In addition to aligning
the incentives of the culture,
one core aspect of culture change is
developing a learning orientation.
How could Unilever develop
a learning organization so
that it would not just reorient once,
but continue to reorient and
adapt as conditions change and through
a better understanding of its environment?
It embarked on quite extensive employee
training and development endeavors.
Both communicating the core purpose of the
institution as well as trying to cultivate
both mindset and other system thinking
approaches amongst its employees.
It's also really pursued
the idea that involving
employees is central to
helping them understand and
feel committed and engaged with
the purpose of the organization.
A couple of examples of how it's done that
include the Dove self-esteem project,
where Dove Soap has been associated
with the opportunity to educate girls.
Between the ages of eight and
17 on the beauty comes from within and
help combat some of the issues that young
women are facing in terms of body image.
Employees have been very involved
in rolling out those campaigns in
diverse countries.
Similarly, Help a Child Reach Five
Campaign is a campaign that has
been teaching children and their parents
about the importance of handwashing and
how to do it effectively.
Employees have been very engaged
in participating in those training
programs, as well.
Learning from stakeholders is another key
aspect of adopting learning orientations.
Not just building your own capacity
within the organization to learn,
but thinking about how you learn
from diverse stakeholders,
bringing as many ideas to the table for
innovation.
One example is Unilever established
the Sustainable Living Lab
which was a scaled approach to stakeholder
engagement where it engaged over 2,000
stakeholders from 70 countries
in a 24 hour live dialogue.
To critique and reflect on progress within
the Sustainable Living Plan thus far, and
to gain new ideas for
how to make it better progress.
Moving to an innovate orientation.
Once the organization is reoriented and
is aligning culture and learning
with sustainability, how can it then
move to a platform of innovation?
One of the things that Unilever has put
a lot of emphasis on is designing new
products and business models that
tackle sustainability challenges.
The Sunlight and
Lifebuoy soaps are two great examples.
Lifebuoy soap, in particular,
is one you can see the children's
hands turning green there.
They designed this soap so that it would
turn green once children had washed
their hands long enough to
eliminate 99.9% of germs.
They also used a redesigned formulation so
that it was a foam wash so
it was more relevant to
places with water scarcity,
it requires a third less water,
because it's a foam soap.
Finally, by doing research on
the germs that cause cholera and
typhoid and eye and
skin infections, the most
significant causes of infant mortality in
a number of the regions where they work.
They reformulated the actual chemical
composition of the soap to be ten
times more effective at killing
those particular germs.
As you saw on the prior slide,
launching campaigns to really help
educate consumers, both in terms of issues
of water scarcity, but also in terms of
the benefits of handwashing for
sustainability and livelihood.
Circular Economy is another area
where Unilever has innovated.
They are taking the traditional
model of take makes waste,
which is take resources from
the natural environment,
make products, use them for a limited
period of time and then dispose of them,
to thinking much more in a circular way.
In the same way that natural systems
pursue a circular approach to waste,
where all waste is recycled and
re-used by the system.
Unilever has incentivized
in groups throughout its
supply chain to think about
Circular Economy opportunities.
Some ideas include using tea bags for
wallpaper, they've gotten plastic
laminate that used to go into landfills
to be now used for school desks.
Mayonnaise turning to biofuel, so
a lot of creativity happening
in their journey to zero waste.
The other thing they're doing
is designing and partnering for
sustainability by engaging broad
participation in problem-solving and
employee incentive programs that
they use to fund projects globally
that are having a significant
impact on carbon reduction.
They are also crowdsourcing
sustainability through the innovation,
Unilever Foundry is a open
innovation platform.
And Unilever post challenges and
opens it up to global participation and
collaboration.
Finally, Unilever has been a leader
in terms of working with unlikely and
partners for sustainability.
Back in the late 1990s, Unilever formed
a partnership with World Wildlife fund,
a global conservation organization to
launch them into a Stewardship Council,
a certification and
eco-labeling organization that would
help create economic incentives for
sustainable fishing by certifying
those fisheries with good practice and
align products from those
fisheries to bear an eco-label.
It also is more recently working with
the Tropical Forest Alliance, a group of
government and consumer good companies
who are dedicating to eliminating
deforestation entirely from the supply
chain of consumer goods companies and
figuring out strategies to
address that challenge.
So let's turn briefly
to sustainable harvest.
A second company, a specialty coffee
importer that sells certified
specialty coffee from about 18 countries,
approximately 20 million pounds
imported each year, and as I mentioned
a sixth of certified US fair trade coffee.
Sustainable harvest started in the late
1980s when its founder Dave Griswold
was volunteering in Mexico for a coffee
organization that supported farmers and
met Pedro, a farmer who came and
represented 40 families and
handed Dave a bag of coffee and
said, this is really good coffee.
I come from the state in Mexico and
we need help finding ways to sell
our coffee, can you help us?
And, so what they did, if you thought
about what this meant, the fact that there
was such a disconnect in the global market
where farmers were producing coffee,
that they had no idea how to
access the global market,
they were just selling on local exchanges.
In order the global market have any
sense of connection to farmers and
actually the potential source
of great quality coffee.
So he decided to form an organization
dedicated to making this connection and
making the market work in favor of
small holder of coffee farmers.
He looked at the global
operating environment.
Recognized the market shocks,
low commodity prices, climate change and
industry consolidation that
coffee farmers were facing.
And he invented a new business model.
He decided to go from a more traditional,
linear supply chain model,
to a much more circular value chain.
So he coined this relationship Coffee,
and the idea was that there would be full
transparency across the value chain,
that all producers would have access
to full information as would everyone
involved in every step of the value chain.
So all prices and costs were
made transparent and shared, but
more importantly, relationships were
built between those individuals so
that sector wide issues could be
discussed and solutions could be found.
He coined the purpose of
the organization as helping farmers
move from subsistence to sustainability.
So thinking about really taking
having an impact on some of
the 25 million small holder coffee farmers
who are struggling to subsistence and
moving them to a viable business,
a sustainable business model.
One of the steps he did to reorient his
company, which is already quite strongly
founded on social, economic, and
environmental vision, was to become a B
corporation or a benefit corporation
in 2008 and hold the organization
accountable to a series of metrics that
B corporations are accountable to.
B corporations are approved to be,
and in fact required to be,
if you get a B corporation status, to be
dedicated to social, environmental, and
financial impact, and
then they are monitored accordingly.
And sustainable harvest as you can see
on this grid performed quite well,
even relative to other B Corporations.
A second step he took was to
align culture and incentive.
So to really think about all
the different aspects of compensation,
hiring practices,
transparency, and connection to farmers.
So as one example, compensation on the
most highly compensated employee in his
company is a ratio 5:1, to the lowest
compensated employee in the United States.
Hiring practices,
quite interesting he hired four systems
thinkers, not copy specialists.
He looks to people who have shown
interest in other cultures,
speak another language, and
think in an integrated way.
Then he teaches them core skills
around the coffee industry.
In terms of the learning orientation, one
of the primary ways sustainable harvest
is developed this learning is through
an event that they've run now for
several years, Let's Talk Coffee.
It's an event that's held in most
usually a coffee growing country,
and it brings together all of
the members of the value chain,
to talk about upcoming issues, what
are the issues that they are not on top of
that they anticipate coming down
the pipe for the coffee industry?
What are producers struggling with?
What are the needs of roasters?
How do they problem solve together?
And how do they anticipate
future challenges?
In addition a lot of deals get
done at Let's Talk Coffee as
roasters meet producers and get to know
their particular coffees and stories.
But most importantly, it's
an opportunity to really problem solve,
and continue to learn together.
Innovation, one of the ways in which
sustainable harvest innovate it
through new products and services.
Case to on the left of the products
that they designed that's won several
awards for innovation.
That's really does for coffee what we have
for wine, which is a way of rating wines
and sharing information between
producers and retailers of that product.
Question coffee is a new band
that they developed to help
farmers really work directly with buyers,
with customers.
So linking farmers
directly to customers and
helping them understand what the issues
are the farmers are facing and
helping educate consumers about
questioning the cost of supply chain.
And finally, they had a huge emphasis
on farmer training and technology.
The company plows back 90% of the gross
revenues into farmer training and
support including the prices paid for
the coffee purchased from farmers.
Technology is included, water saving
technology for coffee processing.
But also really high-tech strategies for
thinking about how understand
the last mile of coffee production.
Where you can look at
individual farmer plots and
see how they connect to particular
coffees that are produced and
understand the profile of the coffees
from a very microscale, individual plot.
Through Let's Talk Coffee and
other platforms, and
the deep relationships they've built
through their relationship coffee model,
they've been able to engage broad
participation in problem-solving.
So when the Roya Crisis broke
out in 2013 A fungus that was
dramatically affecting coffee plants
in Central America in particular.
Sustainable Harvest was positioned to
both perceive the problem very quickly
because it has very regular visits
to its producers on the ground,
through it origin offices.
These offices based in countries of
origin where the coffee is grown.
So they were able to perceive
the problem quickly and
through their relationship leverage
scientists and agronomists to really
figure out what were the best approaches
for averting the spread of the disease.
Addressing plants that were already
diseased, educating farmers so
that they would know
the tradeoff between different
approaches like the use of fungicides or
not.
And they convened several Let's Talk Roya
events where they brought different
stakeholders together, provided training
kits to farmers, responded to questions.
Even brought in lenders to help consider
how to assist the farmers with multi year
loans for replanting a number of their
farms that had been so badly damaged.
And then similar to Unilever working
creatively with diverse partnerships,
Sustainable Harvest has done the same.
In addition to working with
certifiers to validate and
third party certify their fair trade and
ecologically, sustainably grown coffee.
And Root Capital,
one of the lenders they work with.
They formed a major partnership with
Bloomberg to use non-profit capital to
reach tens of thousands of
Rwandan women who are displaced.
And for whom coffee growing is
a wonderful opportunity for
building a sustainable livelihood.
So through these programs of training and
support,
Rwandan women have been able to
not just cultivate coffee, but
cultivate premium quality coffee and
reach consumers directly.
So as we think about these examples and
what it means for
building a sustainable organization,
we have lots of data in terms of
the Harvard Business Review report that
summarizes recent academic research.
And business experience related
to what the business case is for
integrating sustainability at the core.
And we've got global
moves by groups of CEOs
to think about the UN Sustainable
Development Goals for example.
The 17 goals that the United Nations
has put forward as our
goals of a global community to
achieve sustainable development.
And we now have CEOs articulating
the $12 trillion opportunity that
those goals present.
So what does this mean for your business?
It's about reflecting on how your core
purpose might align with sustainability.
And then thinking about
how to use orientations
that will help drive you towards progress.
Both in terms of achieving and
maximizing the impact of your purpose and
thriving in the context of a highly
complex and changing environment.
I think Paul Coleman sums
it up best when he says,
we are at a turning point in history.
A point where we all need to change for
human life on the planet
to continue to prosper.
A new business model with sustainability
at its heart is vital for
quality of life around
the globe to improve.
Only the businesses that
grasp this will survive.
Only those who grow
sustainably with thrive.
So I'm looking forward to your thoughts
and we can take a few questions.
But first I'm going to turn it over to who
will give you a bit of information about
our upcoming enrollment programme.
>> Thank you very much Julia,
this was extremely interesting.
And I think also inspiring to all of us
listening to the webinar to think about
how we might be able to look differently
at the organizations that we work in and
contribute to a more
sustainable society over time.
So with that I'd like to
turn it over to Julia and
we will engage in a few
questions that we'll be taking.
Again we'll answer as many questions as
we can in the short time that we have.
And a reminder that the recording of
the webinar will be sent to all of you
who have been on the line with us today so
that they can review the material again.
So Julia one question that has come
in has to do with the relationship,
difference, and similarities
between corporate responsibilities,
CSR and sustainability.
And how you see that connection?
>> Great question.
And I think it is quite different
corporate sustainability
of course there's a whole range and
spectrum.
So, one mustn't over simplify that
corporate social responsibility
can often not be linked to core
purpose of the organization.
So it could be for example the donation
of products associated with that business
to people who need them.
Computers to classrooms or
backpacks with particular products
to children in different schools.
Sustainability at the core
is quite different.
It means that you're basically putting
sustainability as core to your strategy.
And designing your entire
business model and
strategy around sustainability objectives.
So really looking at how,
back to connecting with your environment,
understanding it, building
relationships in your value chain.
Understanding the social environmental
impact of your production processes and
your product.
Reorienting your whole system so that
it aligns with the goal sustainability.
Which means taking significant
action internally to track different
kinds of metrics and
that's obviously at one extreme.
But then innovating of course for
sustainability where you're looking
at new business models like the circular
economy or collaborative consumption.
New ways of creating sustainable
sourcing and sustainable value chains so
that it is fully permeated
throughout your organization.
>> So you've given examples of two
kind of for-profit companies that have
been tackling this challenge
of sustainability.
What are some ways that
you've seen non-profit and
government organizations engage
in these type of activity?
>> Well, there's been a big
shift I would say in the last 20
years to really sort of blur the lines
between the different sectors of society.
I think we think of government as
providing some basic services,
civil society being sort of
the watchdog of industry,
and industry being there
to maximize profits.
And I think what we're starting
to see is in the modern context,
with the kinds of challenges that
we're facing in the 21st century,
stakeholders are working kind
of around a new social compact.
Where business, government, and civil
society need to find collaborative models
for working together to
solve complex challenges.
I think that the Tropical Forest Alliance
is a great example,
where governments of countries that are
suffering from significant deforestation.
Indonesia, for example, losing a lot
of tropical rainforest because of palm
oil production has a lot at
stake in thinking, you know,
getting businesses who are driving that
deforestation to think differently.
And then the businesses who are
competitors who are growing palm oil have
a lot at stake in working together.
Because if one business says okay,
we'll take deforestation out of our supply
chain, but the other competitors don't,
they will certainly lose competitive
advantage, at least in the short term.
So this collaboration between competitors
within business, engaging governments, and
then also civil society organizations
who often have a lot of scientific and
community knowledge in terms of how
to make change are really essential.
>> Great, so we've had a number of
questions come up around metrics and
measuring success.
I think you've shared a number of
examples from Unilever on how they
measure both their financial impact
as well as their sustainability.
Or environmental impact.
Do you have other examples from
other companies or what should
somebody think about as they're designing
some metrics for their organization?
>> Well, I think first is having a
thorough understanding of what the impacts
are and of course, having a clear
understanding of what your goals are.
And then designing custom
metrics accordingly.
But certainly,
the templates that are out there,
I think the B corporation
template is a great template.
It looks at all the environmental,
social, and governance factors.
So human rights is becoming a stronger and
stronger issue now,
and most certifications don't
actually address that yet.
So businesses that are kind of at
the forefront, back to kind of perceiving
changes in the environment and
anticipating and responding.
They are perceiving that human
rights is becoming a bigger and
bigger issue, slave labor and
other labor rights issues.
And so they are already proactively
tackling those even though the full
systems and metrics and
measurement tools are not yet in place.
Sustainable Harvest, for example,
developed its own system where it uses its
staff at the origin offices to go and
conduct surveys of producer
groups to identify whether or not there
are any issues related to slave labor.
It's not yet third-party certified,
but it's at least one indicator to
Sustainable Harvest if there
are problems and issues there.
So, it's part looking at
the models that are out there and
then it's part anticipating and perceiving
what are becoming current concern and
then designing your own tool
that suite your own industry.
>> Great.
Another question that came up
had to do with geography.
So are there particular geographies
where you see more energy and
activity around this or
where this is perhaps more required?
Or is this more of
a global level activity?
>> That's a very good question.
I mean, of course there are different
drivers in different regions.
But if you look at the developing world,
economic term called emerging markets,
I like to consider more
of developing countries.
There are a lot of challenges that
are being faced there in terms of resource
scarcity, moves from rural
to urban environment, and
the stress that places on
already strained infrastructure.
And so there are tremendous
opportunities for innovation there.
And one thing Unilever has recognized,
and other major companies has recognized,
that if they don't use their basis
in these countries to innovate in
response to these incredible challenges.
There are plenty of local
competitors emerging who
are taking on those
challenges in innovating.
So, in a sense they have
to re-orient that way and
build their local capacity to innovate
in response to some of these challenges.
In terms of sustainability demand from
consumers, there's certainly a lot
more in the United States than Europe
that's driving a lot of the quest for
product that could be
certified as sustainable.
Though, it really depends where you look,
but again, taking assistance perfecting,
these are global challenges.
And the key is to then orient based on
where you have an impact to align with
the sustainability challenges and goals.
>> All right, so we are,
thank you very much Julia.
We're at the top of the hour so we do
not have time for additional questions.
But hopefully,
you all have enjoyed the webinar and
the information that has been
presented as much as I have.
I'd like to encourage all of
you again to visit our website
globalimpact.stanford.edu and find out
more information about the program that
we'll be offering in September and
hopefully some or
many of you can join us there.
And we will also be having
additional webinars and
we'll be sending along information
on upcoming webinars on this topic.
So with that, I wish you all a good
rest of your day and look out for
the recording of the webinar which
should be coming to you within the week.
Have a great day everyone.